Israel's warrior politician you'll hear
from co-authors sigil it'sa Tunis Jordan
Miller and Anita Miller who traced the
life of Ariel Sharon from his birth on a
remote farm through his military career
and eventual emergence as Israel's prime
minister this program runs an hour and
15 minutes
good evening I'd like to welcome all of
you to the boxtroll at chestnut court
and especially our authors our three
authors tonight Anita and Jourdan Miller
and sig elites a Tuni they have chosen
to write about a man that raises
eyebrows in today's world our realtor
owned the name of the book sharone
Israel's warrior politician tells us
about a man that many of us are fearful
of today or questioning about don't know
too much about and this is really the
first biography in English that helps
clarify who this man is what he
represents we learn about his youth up
to the present day it is a very detailed
examination of his life and with doing
that there's sort of a delicate balance
that one has to strive for when you talk
about Ariel Sharon and the Middle East
today and I think the three authors have
accomplished this they have struck that
balance and so I would like to welcome
them Anita and Jordan Miller and Zig Lee
cig ELISA Tunis I thought I would deal
with one of the questions were asked
most frequently and that is is your book
balanced it's a sort of a challenging
question but a reasonable one and it's
in fact a much more complicated sort of
question than we'd realized especially
judging by some of the press notices
we've had so far we think it's a fair
presentation because we didn't intrude
ourselves into the narrative we didn't
make judgments we didn't say well he did
this because you know he never had any
oatmeal we're innocent when he was a kid
so he committed this sort of sin or he
has this kind of flaw we we gave the
story told the story of Ariel Sharon
through the the mouths and observations
of the characters in the book
selves there's no discernible viewpoint
in this book there's a great deal of
information and if it does tilt one way
or another it's because the force of the
weight of that material causes the tilt
not because we push the reader in one
direction or the other you'll find
information in this book I think that
hasn't really appeared anywhere else
we've reported information about the
two-year-old al-aqsa intifada
which is not widely known because it's
only just recently been published in
Israel and also information about Sabra
and Shatila and which everyone knows
it's a very explosive issue and we have
information about which I think shed
some additional light on it so that a
topic which is usually very very
explosive and very emotional is perhaps
a little more logical and light as in
this information the book is balanced as
I said the principal characters in the
seemingly endless conflict you can see
how they've behaved and as a result I
think you'll be able to make logical
conclusions about what's possible in the
Middle East because as everyone knows
it's a problem that seems insoluble as a
way of underscoring what I've emphasized
about the balance of the book I'd like
to simply cite two recent reviews David
Price Jones had a two-page notice in the
National Review in the September 16th
issue and David Unger did a full-page
treatment in the New York Times Book
Review last Sunday Mr Price Jones main
criticism of our book and he criticizes
it roundly was that it was too objective
we had a little trouble coming to grips
with that because we've never been
accused before of an excess of fairness
I mean I don't know how something can be
too objective but that's what he accused
us of he sort of took our methodology as
it were and used it against us on the
other hand David Honor in the New York
Times Book Review was also critical of
the book one of his objections like that
of mr. price Jones's
was that it doesn't make judgments in
other words it's to objective it sounds
rather familiar I'm going to try to be
balanced here if I can and say that mr.
price Jones wanted more or less
unvarnished praise of mr. sharone while
mr. Unger was looking for more or less
an unvarnished condemnation of him I
stand by we all stand by the position we
took in crafting sharone Israel's war a
politician but of course it's up to the
readers to decide so with that comment
I'll turn it over to Anita it was very
difficult to sort of do this book
because Sharon's own autobiography came
out in 1989
and the only other biography of him that
was written was written by a man who
really hates him named Ben Zeeman in the
mid 80s that was written in Hebrew and
and was actually translated into English
as the first book written in English
from the start so information about him
between you know the late 80s and now
you had to sort of find and the way that
that we decided to find it obviously was
by going to newspaper articles and also
computer printouts of things and
interviews with Sharon and Siegel II
went to Israel a couple of times and
spoke to people who knew him and were
familiar with him so we had literally
thousands and thousands of newspaper
articles and practically every article
had a different view or a different
picture or some extra information or not
and it was a question of putting all
this together to try to create a picture
of someone who has unquestionably
changed over the years
I mean Sharon is not the same man today
that he was in 1982
it was as bad in 82 as he's been
presented to be but he's certainly
different now and he has evolved because
in the early interviews his position was
that the Palestinians should all go to
Jordan because Jordan was where they
should be and a mine should be their
capital and not Jerusalem he's since
moved away from that position he now is
willing to to say that it would be a
good idea to have a Palestinian state
although certainly he will never at
least willingly I think have a state
that was as as flexible and broad as the
one that it would Barak offered Arafat
at Camp David although he is you know
you can't always say what he will or
will not do but it looks to me as though
that's his position you know to be I've
been asked a lot of questions about him
and his his personality and what he's
like and whether he's capable of change
and I think he has changed I think that
most people who have developed attitudes
towards Iran know relatively little
about him in in detail he's certainly
been capable of being extremely harsh
and as particularly in the early part of
his career but after he was elected
prime minister he did attempt to
eradicate some of this negative picture
buying it for instance after the disco
bombing he he didn't retaliate and then
of course he was caught between people
who wanted him to retaliate and the
others who didn't want him to retaliate
and he didn't retaliate for the longest
time and then he retaliated because the
suicide bombings continued but he was
obviously trying to deal with his
reputation which is sort of
international and it's not a good
reputation at all he was trying to
mitigate that
I think he's in a position now where
perhaps he's not that worried about it
anymore but we discovered a lot of
things that we didn't know because when
we started this book we also had a
negative picture of him and I've been
asked why do people think he's so awful
and after dealing with the situation in
this book I would say it's because of
the the the press in Israel operates
from the left and he has a lot of
enemies and the picture that has emerged
has been a pretty nasty one and I don't
think that he's been as bad as the press
has presented him and you can you can
judge for yourself because we've
included a tremendous amount of comment
from both sides on his behavior and on
his attitudes for instance most people
don't realize that he has this son named
Al Murray who is a sort of a not exactly
a peacenik but it's a sort of
middle-of-the-road person and he says
about Omri Omri taught me that
everything is not black and white
Omri taught me that there are gray areas
and so he listens to army and army he
sent army to talk to Arafat's people who
who liked him and they were they were
dealing with each other and then the the
the people in the last of Labor people
became very angry about this and they
said this is nepotism you can't send
your son to talk to the Palestinians
because he's not a member of the
government he wasn't elected and the
Attorney General handed down a decision
that said that you can only send Omri
there if you get special permission from
the government first so this is the kind
of stuff that goes on in this country
where people who really want peace at
the same time are so upset and and and
just like him so intensely that if he
does try to move in a certain direction
they don't like that either
and so he's caught between the left and
the right in his cabinet because there
are many people
the right of him in his cabinet there
are settlers there who to the right of
him who really want war and so I think
we have to bear all that in mind when we
deal with this and when we talk about
Cherone so now I'll ask singlet to come
and talk about her recent experiences I
just wanted to add a few things that I
think are important if you read the book
you'll I think get a picture of a an
ascent of a leader I think it's
important to see all the steps in
Sharon's ascent to where he is today
which is a prime minister and I don't
think he could could have gotten there
just by chance as a lot of people claim
that he became prime minister because of
a situation where Netanyahu wasn't
running and Barak failed because of the
Camp David failure and therefore Sirhan
stepped in and took it over I don't
think and from from from doing all the
research you could see that he's done
everything that I think any leader
should do and it take the steps and and
go through everything he's gone through
the military he started as a soldier and
he became a general and he didn't just
become a general one day he went through
Wars and he went through battles and he
had to fight through everything inside
and outside and then when he was elected
to the government he was in the
opposition in the beginning so he knew
what it was like to be in the opposition
in 1977
terone was elected to to the government
and became part of the Likud
and since the likud was the winning
party Sharon was able to actually get a
minister position and from then on he
just was able to learn the the tactics
in in politics and he actually thought
that it was funny that he was such a big
deal in the army and everybody was
listening to him and suddenly he said he
was supposed to sit around with people
who had no idea about what security is
and he was supposed to listen to them
but he learned a lot I think he did and
I think that it's very interesting to
see because I don't think he would have
made a good prime minister if he had
been elected even four years ago I think
he's made a lot of mistakes but he has
learned from them and it's very
interesting to see his way in getting
there and and the other thing is I
learned that he has a lot of character
he's just a person of character I think
we don't even need to analyze him
because it's just there I read somewhere
that Umberto Eco wrote and that sort of
seems appropriate to say that um he said
that Oedipus was there before Freud so
you know there is a character and you
could just read about it and make your
own judgment so that's about it
you probably have questions I hope so
who would like to start yes I have a
question and two anecdotes the
questioner that just finished moshe
dayan autobiography and he a backhanded
compliment he said as a soldier but
undisciplined he couldn't be controlled
very critical the second thing is I was
the deputy chief scientist for Medicine
a few weeks and a few weeks before the
Yom Kippur War we had a small dinner
with Sharon and our host made the
mistake of saying why should a soldier
go into politics or should he well the
short fuse Tehran has and he exploded
and we heard him brought off the walls
saying why shouldn't a politician a
soldier go into politics the second
episode I crossed asurim bridge the
pontoon bridge during the war the
soldiers adored him and this is a man
who inspired trust so my question then
is what do you think most today on
statement was he undisciplined was he
difficult he was difficult because once
he made up his mind to do something and
he thought he was right he wanted to do
it and Dayan on the other hand you know
changed his mind and I don't think he
had a traumatic
Dayan and he had a relationship I think
they liked each other a tremendous
amount but yeah I think I think he he
did what he had what he wanted to do I
don't know if you'd call it
undisciplined he was certainly
contentious I suppose it's a question of
which adjective you you want to use
wouldn't take orders from superiors well
he did take orders well there were
occasions like in the past where he
didn't disobeyed orders that's true
it was impetuous and he was contentious
but at the same time you have to admit
that his development of commando tactics
is really what made the Israeli army
what it is today
he had a great belief and still does
intra mobility
he had a huge controversy with high
Ambala who was a chief of staff at the
time because the Bala of line was sort
of like the Maginot Line it was rigid it
was just a series of rigid and
placements which along the Suez Canal
and Cherone bum wrapped it in every way
he could because he's not not reticent
at all as we know as it turned out he
was right because the commando tactics
that he developed throughout his
military career actually consist of
tremendous mobility building roads and
supply lines getting when you're
attacked attacked back never let an
ambush
vanquish you always fight back as though
you're the ambusher so all these ideas
about about tactical mobility were
things that became a sort of a standard
part of Israeli military training and
that's why he felt so certain because he
lot of the officers were incompetent
that's true and and he did have a great
deal of trouble getting all of his own
ideas adopted and when they weren't
adopted he became very impatient
the Mitla pass is an example of where
where this impetuosity led into a sort
of a disaster he has done that it's true
but that doesn't that doesn't mean that
his his methods in general or his
tactical abilities he did he did follow
orders and they had they didn't know
what they were doing going in and you
know so he did what they told him to do
and he was wandering around as he said
you know like like an idiot
across yeah a few days before the his
victory they were basically in it
especially on the 8th the war started on
the 6th and the Egyptians crossed the
canal and Dayan at that point was so
taken back he couldn't believe that it
happened that he let it happen basically
and he said
famous thing that he said was that the
third temple is coming down and and then
Sharon tried to to explain and to to
tell the Diane and golden everybody in
the government that these really should
attack back and cross the canal right
away but they wouldn't let him and then
only a few days later he got the okay
and they had to suffer a lot of them
they literally did save the day with
that tactic otherwise the Israelis would
have lost the war would have been a
disaster sometimes he's unruly but it
actually worked out okay mostly well
yeah sort of
sometimes sometimes it's a little bit of
his childhood and if he showed any of
those leadership qualities well she was
growing up yeah you talked to some of
the people yeah I know people who talk
he he was uh he was a very good and
disciplined student he did everything he
was asked to do actually and something I
think it's in our first chapter where he
was in probably third or fourth grade
and the kids decided that the pupils he
called him that they decided not to go
to school because they did not like
corner of the teachers and Sharon said
that that's not a way to deal with it
you should actually talk to the teacher
and agree on you know making it better
and not just cut school so he was
actually you know his parents were very
strong and he just he followed orders
when he was a kid he wasn't they he grew
up in this moshav which unlike a kibbutz
and it's a it's a farm but it's not
communal people do share some things but
but not everything and his father was a
strong individualist I think to the
point of being eccentric and rather
pompous and the people in the motion I
didn't like his father at all but they
all I
I reek as they called him and it's his
history as sister and so he was popular
and he was popular when he went to high
school in tel-aviv but is but his father
was just liked and some of that strong
individualism obviously he inherited
because his father it was all so I guess
they were labor people but they really
didn't like the idea of community they
weren't that they did not agree to
everything labor politics was standing
for and this is why his parents were not
liked in their community because they
did have other opinions and they lived
in a community where everybody had to
have the same opinion it was a socialist
still sort of socialist you know it was
and if you if you didn't agree with you
know what everybody was thinking then
you were sort of an outcast there's an
incident later that his son mentioned he
has two sons he had three what one was
killed in a terrible accident when he
was 12 with a shotgun and his sons after
the Sabra and Shatila thing they they
have a big farm in the Negev and after
the Sabra and Shatila saying his father
was pretty much vilified and the the
people in the nearby cubits cubits
wouldn't have anything to do with them
and they really sort of isolated the
whole family from her own sons I mean
they had great difficulty socially
because I mean you know as a society
it's an amazing society because on the
one hand you have people you know with
these strong opinions who could you know
really punish somebody for doing
something that they thought was was
wrong and on the other hand you have the
Knesset in which some of the members who
represent the Israeli Arabs are
completely hostile to the government and
even go and visit you know in Syria
and talked against the government in a
situation where they are virtually at
war and that's allowed which I don't
think in this country we would be too
thrilled with some member of Congress
who ran around saying that he thought
Osama bin Laden was a great fellow you
know so it's it's a strange sort of
society in some ways is rigid and in
other ways it's extremely flexible yeah
getting back to his childhood that I
just wanted to mention too that his
father was was rather arrogant it's true
he wanted to be called agronomist signer
and [ __ ] that was his name because
he felt that he he deserved that sort of
well-trained agronomist and uh but in
addition to that and of course the all
of his neighbors were very offended by
this as you can understand he also was
the only one who built a fence around
his orchards and to keep you know all
the riffraff out I suppose but they were
also very cultivated people I mean they
loved classical music they loved
literature and his father was an
extremely Arden scientist and this was
something that sharone himself grew up
with and he got the name took the name
sharone by the way [ __ ] was their
real original name and as became because
of ben-gurion and gorian started a sort
of trend of taking Hebraic names rather
than European one so shina Minh became
sharone later on in his career and Ben
green name was Green Green yeah before
he was but he did take violin lessons
for a short time by the way so did his
sister he gave them up very quickly but
his sister went on but but they one of
the people that say leads brother
interviewed in co pham law which was the
name of the moshav said there was a lot
of intelligence in that house I mean
they all recognized that these people
are still living there they all
recognize that the sure owns
were very cultivated cultural sort of
people and they respected them for that
even though they were annoyed with them
for their arrogance or mostly the father
really somebody asked me whether he had
only a high school education which to
some extent it's true that he did enroll
in the Hebrew University in fact he was
studying Arab culture because he wanted
to know more about it but he had to
leave because of the war situation he
was called to form unit 101 in the
middle of his history classes and he
decided to take on take on unit 101 he
thought it was more interesting at that
time degree I was gonna say he also
studied Lawson he studied at this
British military training unit for about
a year wasn't it which he liked he liked
very much he liked the protocol he liked
of that sort of of orderliness he likes
order Sharon when every whenever I would
read about him or talk to people he's
the kind of person that just likes order
he was really impressed when he went to
the Far East and he said and he would
see in Hong Kong the students going to
school and they're all going in order
and they're all in uniforms he thought
he was really cool and and he likes that
he says that there's a lot of order in
nature and nothing is not there just for
for any odd reason he always tries to
explain work as a farmer he's an avid
farmer he tries to explain to people how
why one side of the hill is is barren
and the other side is all green green
luscious and so he has this thing about
order and he thinks that everything
comes with a reason but it's interesting
too that even though he loved order the
unit 101 which he formed which was that
original commando unit really had no
traditional discipline in the sense of
having uniforms or
saluting you know people saluting their
superior officers and all this that
there was a very loosely organized sort
of arrangement although of course they
were they were very very rigorously
trained in fact almost to the point of
exhaustion they're only forty I think
altogether in this special sort of
special forces unit they were like the
Green Berets or or the Delta Force or
something like that they were extremely
clever even though they did lose a lot
of their battles
it was the core of the training of the
what became the IDF it was it was so
loose that sometimes officers would take
orders from privates I mean which is
very hard for people who know about
traditional army units to sort of
visualize they it's a strange society
it's different from most societies I
think that was one of the things that
struck me as I was working with all this
stuff you know that is nothing like you
imagine no and I mean one of the things
he did when he when he became prime
minister which no one thought he ever
would it's a matter of fact one of the
guys on the Left said Sharon I think he
said there's a 99 or something he said
Sharona has about as much chance to be
prime minister as he has to become a
tennis champion and if you've seen his
picture you know I'm not gonna become a
tennis champion but now I'm lost now he
still is unifying he said yeah when he
got in he said one of the things he
wanted for his cabinet which was a very
large cabinet because they had to
include you know the left and the right
and he said Aaron banana and air and
Druze yeah and he said they have to get
there on time which was a new idea and
they have to not keep interrupting each
other they have to wait for somebody to
finish the sentence before they start
talking which obviously was also a new
idea I doubt very much if it works and
they eat while reading he likes food
somebody once said that if you put ten
Israelis in a room and ask them to
discuss a subject you'd get ten distinct
opinion
on that subject which is sort of a
metaphor for how difficult it is to form
a coalition government especially in
Israel where people have very strong
opinions and he's got to balance as we
said before all of these left and right
elements and it's not easy because
there's not just the issue of the war
which of course the most obvious and
most difficult one to to come to grips
with but they're all these budget issues
and issues with the Orthodox as opposed
to the people who are who are more
secular it's a very difficult kind of
system and and he's deserved some good
marks I think for managing to keep this
coalition together to meet with him
personally any of them no we didn't seek
a chance actually 10 people asked this
question a lot and actually in the
archives that we read in thousands and
thousands of websites and you know
printouts from various newspapers we
read a lot of interviews with sharone
and if you ever saw the candidate when
Robert Redford is riding in the back of
the car he's sort of repeating this
litany well it sort of begins to sound
like that after a while because you know
exactly what he's going to say when the
question is posed so I guess what I'm
trying to say is we didn't really need
to talk to outsiders and I think in
order to get a really really good
interview with him we'd have to stick to
him 24 hours a day for maybe 2 or 3
years and maybe then you'll get
something but otherwise it really most
interviews he says the same thing he
goes back to the war of independence he
goes back to 1948 he still thinks that
Israel is at a war of independence and
and that's what he likes to say and he
talks about security and peace and the
water problem which is another thing
that he likes to talk about which it is
the problems did you have a question
did his what influence was his mother if
any they keep talking about his father
all the time and also did he have a
mentor in his life earlier well his
mother it's a kind of a sad story
because his father was active in the
Zionist movement in Russia no death I
believe was and after the Communists
took over Zionists lives were in danger
his mother was in medical school and all
she wanted in life was to be a doctor
but when the when the Communists got in
his father she they were married they
left very quickly and they moved to this
Mossad yeah so she never was able to
finish her education and she I think was
quite embittered by that throughout her
whole life right as it started is when
the Communists began you know they
started killing you know Zionists in
fact he he was supposed to go to a
meeting and he was delayed everybody at
that meeting was arrested and so when he
heard that he said to her we have to go
and she her she wanted her son to be a
professional person to be you know
educated because I think it says you
know and I think that did influence him
and as far as a mentor is concerned I
would you say maybe ben-gurion but not
really they weren't that close but he
did think very highly of him and
ben-gurion liked him but they didn't he
always talks about him and I read it in
a few places that sharone tries to to
make it look like he was very close to
ben-gurion but he wasn't as close as he
wants you to think that he was and but
they were but I I've seen letters that
ben-gurion wrote to him and they're very
personal and and they're very much in
favor and he told them one letter said
to him that ben-gurion wrote to Sharon
he said them I've seen you grow I've
seen you change you
you did not in the beginning you didn't
follow all the rules and he didn't do
everything you asked but you have made
it into in a way a great general he said
them and so I think ben-gurion if
anything he like beggin to but not in
the beginning but he's such an
independent person I don't think yeah he
goes his own way which is maybe that's
why he has so many enemies because he
does have a lot of enemies and you know
everything he's done in his life has
been heavily heavily criticized i mean
his his he married a woman he met on in
the moshav and she was killed in an
automobile accident and that's when he
had this one son the one that was also
killed he's had some tragedy in his life
and this margulies sister came to help
him take care of the little boy and she
and Sharona eventually married Lily she
died about two years ago of lung cancer
but when Ben Zeeman talks about it he
implies very strongly that well some
people a lot of people try to imply that
he had an affair with the second wife
who was his sister before the first went
while he was still married for yeah
we've even heard you know some man in
Israel wrote this this picture book well
he's a psychoanalyst and he said clearly
Sharon wanted his wife to be killed in
this accident because he didn't take
good care of the car and another proof
of that is that after she was killed he
kept the car which you know person would
otherwise okay I mean if that's the sort
of thing that we you know the it's quite
revolting and it it's it's as I say it
strikes every sometimes he walks into it
as for instance when he went to the
Temple Mount in 2000 because he was
running against Barack and I think he
wanted to prove that if you if you went
to the Temple Mount in Jerusalem you
were in great danger and Barack wanted
to to give East Jerusalem to Arafat so
he went to the Temple Mount
and the Intifada followed I don't think
he caused the Intifada the evidence is
that the Intifada was planned for
November but that when Shirin went in
September to the Temple Mount they
thought this is as good a chance as any
we'll have to push it up a little bit
and that's why it started and they named
it the al-aqsa Intifada because but the
Mitchell report concluded that it was
planned before that yeah in fact we have
quote in the book of the communications
director I think it was of the PLO had
said as much he said that the Intifada
was actually planned for November of
that year and they used the incident of
Sharon's going to the Temple Mount as a
excuse to start it immediately so then
they could they could blame him you know
what was it that you would he but he
gets himself into a lot of trouble and
by his his own fault last week he was
interviewed for Rosh Hashanah for the
Israeli papers and this is two years
after the al-aqsa Intifada started and
he was asked what if somebody asked him
to let him to approve going now into the
Temple Mount what would he say and he
said well you know it's a place where
all Jewish people should be able to go
to but I don't think it's a good idea
there is one another question we often
get asked user is he capable of making
peace does he have any flexibility that
sort of thing well there is one historic
incident where he did show flexibility
and that is when when Israel and Egypt
made peace over the Sinai there was a
well established of kibbutz called yaa
meat town rather sorry called a
settlement called yum eat and that was a
sticking point in coming to to grips
with with the Egyptian peace and he
agreed to have it dismantled and of
course they dismantled it in a way that
nothing's ever been dismantled before I
mean they took the plumbing pipes out of
the ground the wiring and they just and
raised it completely so so he is capable
of two answers but even more than that
at the Camp David the original cameras
that had to do with the Middle East with
Jimmy Carter and bacon and said that
there was a point where everything was
gonna blow into pieces just like what
happened with our front and it did but
in that case said that wasn't gonna sign
it and Bagan wasn't gonna sign it was
actually begging who was giving
everybody a hard time because he was
looking at every word and in the contour
in the agreement and he wanted you know
every word to mean what it actually
means and he wasn't flexible at all and
at one point in Sadat was already
calling his helicopters and he packed
his bag then he was gonna leave and then
Bagan decided that he was gonna go with
it and he was going to agree that to
return to Sinai and to return the land
and also to let the the settlements go
you know the Israeli settlements at
worth Sinai but the reason that he said
that their reason he agreed was Ariel
Sharon Aaron was not there he was not
invited because of Moshe Dayan
and Ezer Weizman who didn't want him to
come and he was our cultural minister
and a cabinet he stayed in Israel and
was on the phone with begging the entire
time and and begging had to get Jerome's
approval because he said if Chiron
agrees use more right wing than I am
then I will agree so they called him up
and he told him what the deal was and he
said if I agree we have to return this
island we have to make all these
concessions and Chiron said just go
ahead with it saying and he did so guys
and then also he there were other times
well he went to the why
meeting with Arafat with Netanyahu even
though he hated hates Arafat and he
didn't think the why agreement was a
good idea but he went because he was in
his foreign minister so I mean he's not
it's rigid and I mean people were very
upset because Bush called him a man of
peace I think he's capable of making
peace to a point is there's a lot of
things he won't it's not the first thing
in his agenda that's for sure no his
fight he would he is capable of making
the first thing I said Genda is security
you know and after that comes peace and
then we've all I've been asked many many
times you know isn't it true that he and
Arafat are just two old men who don't
like each other and that's a pretty
simplistic approach to this because I
don't know he doesn't like Arafat at all
he's had experience with Arafat since
1964 with a lot of terrorist activity
and they're not the same kind of people
they're both in their 70s but they're
not the same kind of people sure Owen
has been in the government for years
he's had various administrative posts he
was minister of housing it was Minister
of Trade he was Minister of Agriculture
he was foreign minister and so on and
Arafat has really not had any
administrative jobs or supposedly any
administrative capabilities even
ministered a lot of the money you know
yes so I think that but I think that's I
don't think I mean I don't think these I
don't think this is what is moving this
situation to old men who don't like each
other I think that's pretty much more of
a spiritual leader to his people and
Sharona is much more of a doer he he
accomplishes a lot more what he says is
he makes facts on the ground that's what
he always likes the same more questions
hmm you suggested earlier that Chevron's
temperament has evolved over the years
and I took you to mean his ideology even
has softened a bit as time has gone by
to what do you ascribe that if that's
true other than mellowing that age any
softening in his approach well I think I
said I think his son the older son
armory too had had a great deal to do
with it and I think also as time goes by
people do get a different view of things
I think that I think he has he hasn't
softened completely he is volatile any
and he he says things you know without
thinking you know for instance this
thing he said but infuriated the
jordanians he said he was going to there
was some sort of terror it will militant
in in Jordan and and he said we're gonna
kill this man he went to Jordan and said
this so the Jordanians got very very
upset and furious and was all sorts of
uproar and everything and they when he
got back to Israel he said oh you know
don't worry you know we know we're not
gonna kill him there we'll kill him but
we're not gonna kill Jordan you know cuz
that's the sort of thing you know he
just sort of blurts these things out and
it gives us an impression it so he is
volatile and he's also a very poor
speaker yeah very he makes bad speeches
and his English is really awful so as a
PR person he he doesn't work too well
but then neither does Arafat very much
maybe we got a touch on a little bit on
Sabra and Shatila because that's always
the incident of the tragedy the zas tur
that they people who don't like your own
raise the
except I always thought that Sharon was
the commanding general in Lebanon at the
time actually he was defense minister so
he was back in Jerusalem so that that
was a surprise for me actually the
information that we have in the book
that I mentioned in the beginning was
that there's testimony from various
people who had been there now it's 20
years after the anniversary of Sabra and
Shatila Massacre I should say and it
there are some new evidence and new
testimony that are coming out and we
have them in one of our chapters I think
it's called it's not much to that anyway
but there's a there are a few one of one
of the things that we wrote there was a
man named Antoine laughs Lochhead and
Orlov had actually and he was the head
of the our Lebanese army the Christian
army and he said that because he was the
head of the Lebanese army this after the
massacre Elie Hobeika who was leading
the phalange into into the savage tila
camps and who was leading the murders
basically I came to him and he said they
came to him right after the massacre
they're still all blood on their clothes
and he asked him what happened and they
told him detail in detail
minute-by-minute account of what
happened and they told him that nobody
in Israel had any idea that this was
gonna happen and Sharon had no idea that
this was gonna happen
not that you know it makes him it
absolved he should have not let them in
I
you know everybody says so and and he
actually was condemned by the Commission
for food Oona and he was let go of his
post as defense minister so he does bear
responsibility but a lot of people think
that he actually planned it and and that
is definitely not true according to well
sued Time magazine because they said
that he did plan it and it's quite
obvious that he didn't plan it what he
was thinking of what he was doing one of
the generals who was there said that
there were 2,000 Palestinians in that
camp and there were 150 of these
Falangists and he said which you can
accept or not we thought that we might
have to go in and rescue them now that
that quarter could not be true but you
know there was that was his testimony
that was that's what he said it's it's
in the book this is recently he said
this name was a mere drawer and he was
they had of Northern Command for the
Israeli army at that time so but that's
something that that she was still trying
to live down that was Jews yes was it
that he was chosen to lead the the coud
for the presidency prize how how did you
happen to be the head of the lagoon he
was voted by the Likud Party it was like
a primary and he was running and
Netanyahu was supposed to run but he
didn't and so he won he couldn't because
of a law but they could have actually
arranged something but they didn't but
they didn't know and sort of a snit and
sharone was the only one left and that's
and I guess when you're the head of the
party then you become the candidate
right and he was the head of the party
while Barack was in power so he was in
opposition to Barack and
so you would publish articles and
letters and papers like the New York
Times The Jerusalem Post about what he
thought Barack was doing wrong and he
was very dedicated he wanted everybody
to know what he was thinking it but he
did it in a in a very democratic way he
published letters and the and he talked
and he he didn't try to do any maneuvers
to get Barak out of office Brock did it
to himself you know so rock was you know
because of the Camp David staying right
Barack and actually there's a lot of
stuff in this book quotes from from
Palestinians who wanted Sharon to win
that election because they said if
Sharon wins he will be so out of control
and so horrible that international
opinion will turn against Israel and
well you know he'll he'll be kicked out
his government will fall they also
thought that Bush would be much more
friendly to them than Clinton who they
they thought was unfair they were a
little wrong about both things and it
shows you that you really can't when you
know people keep saying this will happen
and that will happen if you do this and
you do that but you can't in
international politics I guess you can't
be that crafty because the world is full
of surprises and anything else
no no more questions
well what do we do now we you know we
rather thought you would have thought
you'd have more questions you must ask
us a question Israel I I think from its
earliest years has had a policy of
non-negotiation with terrorists and
swift and fierce retaliation for
terrorist acts to what extent if any did
Chiron play a role in crafting that
policy I think he undoubtedly had a
great great deal of input on that policy
because throughout the 50s all these
forays into Jordan when he was a young
officer in fact there's a very famous
incident which those who are on the very
left who really hates your own always
mentioned in addition to some savage
tiller and that is a town called Kabir
where they routinely went around and
blew up houses now the policy was
supposed to be that a soldier would go
into a house and call out and say is
there anyone in here if you're here get
out now because we're gonna blow up the
house well they blow up I think 40
houses and they were very proud of their
achievement because it was it was it was
a much more kind of widespread ambitious
campaign than they'd ever carried out
before well sadly as it turned out 69
people mostly women and children were
killed and shirome deals with it in his
own autobiography and he mitigates it by
saying that well it was very sad and all
that but it was it was a great military
campaign which is a not exactly good
public relations I don't think so he he
is really the father of the deterrence
policy and he did create a kind of
atmosphere where if there was an attack
they certainly retaliated heavily and
they they tried to preempt further
attacks and I mean this has gone on and
on for decades as you know he said he he
was asked to eradicate terrorism from
Gaza
in the 70s yeah after and now I'm gonna
be one on 72 and he his his policy was
very harsh and he sort of mapped out the
whole area and sort of squares and he he
did eradicate because when he you know
what he did was if somebody well he did
things to people he made them stand in
the Mediterranean he humiliated a lot of
of the people but he was able to
eradicate there was a lot of terror
going on and and these rallies were
scary it was very close to what's going
on today not suicide bombing but it was
just a lot of raids into Israel and
killing a lot of civilians and Gaza is
very heavily populated and Gaza has a
lot of thick orchards and Gaza is a very
difficult place even today these rallies
don't really go in there as much as to
the West Bank because it's just scary
and if you want to go house to house you
know you're gonna get a lot of
casualties on your side so it's sort of
like that what happened in Jenin were in
defensive shield I'm going on a tangent
but there was a there was a the
defensive shield operation had 29
Israeli soldiers that were killed
throughout the entire operation and 23
of them were killed in one day in Jenin
because they went house-to-house and so
that's what they were afraid they're
afraid in Gaza that
if you go house to house you're gonna
end up losing a lot of people and what
Jerome did in the 70s what he took off
he was a head of Southern Command and
Gaza was part of Southern Command and he
was an army and he told the soldiers he
said don't look at it as a big scary
place let's just divide it up into units
and he made a map and he divided it into
two what is it - um
two square miles each 21 square miles
102 square miles and each each unit was
responsible for their square so it
didn't look so you know crazy and scary
and and they were able to do that they
were able to go through every square and
eradicate the terror and they also had
to humiliate a lot of Palestinian men by
having them stand in the Mediterranean
without their shirt or in the middle of
the square and that was their way of
getting information out they got a lot
of information out but they also got a
lot of people to hate them even more you
know so and you pay a price for that the
parents didn't you told the parents you
know if you if you if you get involved
with your children and terrorism give
you some money and a jug of water and
some bread and 22 Jordan he basically
was able to to tell families that if
their kids throw stones that was in the
70s now it's just stones that point then
somebody from that family an adult is
going to be deported and today they
can't do that they have to go to court
and they have to go to the you know High
Court and there has to be a really good
reason before you can deport somebody
who is related to a suicide bomber and
you can definitely not deport anybody
whose kid just threw a stone no well so
no but you can't deport him to Jordan
anyway because the Jordanians don't want
on the right so what they do is deport
them to Gaza yeah after all
let's go to heaven that's what the
second question is the easiest way to
solve all this hullabaloo is to take the
atoms of growth of the sea but there are
three million three million now what is
going to happen after that then I debate
this issue with a friend of mine all the
time if the Arabs live with the Jews
they'll be in paradise but if you
separate them the problems will become
multiplied know what you come from there
what do you think am i stogie sense they
did they were actually living together
to some extent before the Intifada but
now the situation is so horrible that
they can't live together well they're
building a wall which sharone actually
doesn't want to do because he doesn't
want to do it but but they're doing it
anyway I don't know what they can do
that that's one of the problems here I
mean what what do you do and he I think
he will be reelected the election is
supposedly next October
I mean a year from now 2003 I think
she'll be reelected his ranking in the
polls about 70% of the movie about 70%
74 no just large he's actually he's
actually pretty healthy for yeah such a
large Jesus month a 40 year old as a
president and we have no accident we
have yes this why why is it a punishment
to be transferred
the West Bank to Gaza well these people
live in the West Bank they have homes
you know and I was a refugee camp yeah
you know God is not just refugee camp
there are refugee camps in Gaza you guys
is an actual place you know it's it's
it's a city it's got a capital city Gaza
City and it's it's it's a party it's a
Palestinian Authority to belong to the
Palestinian Authority bow down how did
they get job they said you know how do
they get somebody to move the punishment
today again they have to prove that it's
not that easy to do that but if if there
is a suicide bomber then you can take
people and his family if they're found
to actually have helped him and you can
deport them to Gaza from the West Bank
and so it's it's still not the where
they live it's like taking somebody from
Chicago and moving them to another city
it's not 80 people like their home it's
not something that is better than they
can yeah they're much less suicide
bombing coming out of Gaza because there
is an actual border the fence and much
better secure much better yeah almost
everything is controlled they they they
are able to Israelis are able to find
most of the infiltrators yeah yeah they
it's knowledge
knowledge and yet not saying anything or
this one woman who was deported she
helped so belt
the suicide belt for her brother
thankful Shirin and cleaned up gossip in
my first visit the Gaza City in 71 there
were a hundred and seven murders
Arup against air by July the fourth I
spent four months in Gaza City in 73 74
zero
alright so I been told that by the
bombing by getting rid of the alleys and
expanding it who is that Sharon I'm
Diana that was both of them you're right
because Sharon was the the army he was
head of Southern Command and Diane was
Minister of Defense so it was her own
under Diane and yeah that was what you
said is exactly right sigil 8 says
there's been there a couple of times
what you want you to mention yeah just
got ducted she just got back today and I
was telling them that I compared it to
three months ago when I was there in May
June and it's a it's a big difference
because when I was there three months
ago it was scary
it just everybody felt really scared to
go no I'm sorry I'm talking about Israel
inside the Green Line and it was scary
to go to to a coffee shop in Tel Aviv it
was scary to go to a mall it was scary
to go anywhere cause you just felt
really uncomfortable doing anything and
now it's like can i tonday and this is
three months later now the price you
have to pay is that you have to have is
really short soldiers every day in all
of the West Bank and in part of Gaza and
so again the hatred is growing and
Israelis are getting frustrated that
they have to you know play the role of
the mean occupier but in terms of
terrorism the population in Israel they
can live a normal life
for them and some why I felt it I I went
everywhere and nobody you know checks
you it's it just it's a different
feeling and it's only three months later
and it it's because of a lot of military
operations but and I I think it would
have been better if it was through
actually peace and through agreement but
it wasn't possible so they had to do
through military operations your name is
Jamie take a leave the Tunis yes the
Tuesday too so that is an olive and it's
an Arabic name how did you get that
because there are a lot of Jews with
Arabic names just like there are a lot
of Jews with German names cuz Jews have
always taken names from wherever yeah
well my family is from the Middle East
from Israel actually for many
generations and usually Jewish people
wherever they live took on the last
names of the country or they're from so
they live among Arabs so my last name
was there explains to be visible
maybe I'm ignorant what is going to
happen with three million people
if if the Jews are getting it wrong
minted into the ocean like you said into
the Mediterranean then they will not be
Jewish anymore because that's against
what their religion to the Jews well
yeah it doesn't matter no no nobody's
anybody else here's the problem you know
this as well as any of us does that the
problem in the Middle East at the moment
is that Arafat as her own
predicted he was or would be has become
irrelevant
why is he becoming relevant because he
can't control the forces that he should
have controlled a long time ago you know
Hamas Hezbollah Islamic Jihad and even
if he wanted to declare peace he might
get killed or he can't cope with these
people now how do we solve a problem
where you have a group of people and God
knows the people in the settlements are
probably just as just as violent and
determined on their side as Hamas is how
do we mitigate this problem huh you know
you can ask the question but what what
is the answer what is the answer a man
who is happy was well fed and is in
peace does not commit crimes
now if the president of Egypt would get
out and walk in and in that exam they
are entitled that killing that is gone
now somebody who becomes extremely
religious is because he's unhappy if he
is very happy it doesn't care about
religion well I know that's another why
why have Hizballah Islamic Jihad
yeah lots of martyrs why of all those
terrorist group suddenly become
relatively quiet what change to make
this happen how permanent is it is it
just the law or is something going down
that were unaware of they do more in the
West Bank in Gaza but they don't they
don't terrorize Israel proper well it's
the policy of deterrence that is that is
hey there was an agreement there was an
agreement that they said they didn't
sign and some of them said they did sign
but there was at least an effort among
the Arabs for two for a ceasefire and
they said that it doesn't include the
West Bank in Gaza but just the talks
about it I think meant that they're
actually thinking about stopping well
they stopped I mean it goes on all the
time every day I mean they got this huge
bomb that they found just the other day
it's gonna be some people who are gonna
do it even I think there's an awful lot
of ferment with the Palestinian
Authority I mean there's a lot of people
in that area who are sick to death of
Arafat and the whole thing and they want
to change
I think that's distracted them
considerably and the fact that these
really are me is their everyday you'll
be just winning and they never went out
in the beginning they would go out every
time and if you remember Bush would say
you know you must get out you must get
out so they would go out but now they're
there and they're not going anywhere and
that helps that definitely hope it just
deterrence is not a solution obviously
it's just an internship
No we've got to have long-term solutions
the only way we can do that of course is
to have the two sides come together and
negotiate straightforwardly and honestly
and build peace together but that's what
they've been trying to do for 50 years
and and Sharon believes that economics
economic cooperation is very important
and he actually wrote that several times
he thinks that if you are if you if
there's cooperation between Arabs and
Jews economically then that both sides
will have something to lose it from that
attempts to economic cooperation have
been have been stopped by the terrorist
elements on the other side any
Palestinians they would try to do
business with Israelis to set up the
factories in the south by nearby Gaza
and by in the southern area they made
there was a lot of money put into the
the implementation of factories that
would give the Palestinians work and
that would improve their situation but
it was stopped by the Hizballah and I
walk so how do you address this
attention renske had an article in The
Wall Street Journal and he suggested
that the UN and and you take over the
West Bank and get rid of the refugee
camps force see a rich Arab nations to
pay for this get rid of the refugee
camps and build decent housing and build
an infrastructure of education and
healthiest people schools and whatnot
you know and stay there he said three
years I would think there would be
something closer to ten and that after
that was done that maybe then these
people would be in a situation where
they could develop a responsible
government
what they're having a large meeting of
European heads and I don't know if they
want there's so much animus in the EU
and the UN against Israel that I don't
know if that's possible but it struck me
as a sensible suggestion you know that
maybe these people could be helped
because certainly the other Arab
countries are not helping and in this
book there are so many instances of
incitement and horrible things that
these you know people like Mubarak who
they call a moderate but he's constantly
inciting rage and in you know so that
there's this sea of hatred and it's
counterproductive it doesn't help
anybody but they do it because they
don't want people to take a good look at
them yeah back to your book what you're
having
does sharone ever review the other
religious quote hotspots that have been
going on for 50 or 100 years in Northern
Ireland the Middle East and other parts
the hot spots in the Middle East
Afghanistan and you mean does he use
them as parallels in any way or did
anybody refer to any of this is
something similar because of either
religious beliefs or yeah I think people
do people you know people do say well
you know religion fundamentalism is this
is a core of all this and it you know it
goes on in Ireland well I don't think
that Shalom himself doesn't look at that
so much history as a picture and he
looks at he talks about it from a Jewish
perspective always there is famous
speech about Czechoslovakia he said I
think it was about a year ago and he was
talking to the u.s. basically he's
talking to the Israelis but he meant for
Bush to listen to that and he said don't
do to Israel what Chamberlain did you
know so no his his perspective this is
narrow in that sense and I think yeah
his concerns was survival because these
people are being threatened with with
extinction that's what that's what they
want to do that's what the Hezbollah and
Hamas want to do and they're very frank
about it so this this is he sees himself
as somebody who's trying to protect he
said don't you call him a Judea fill or
a nationalist or what that's his primary
concern and that's why he does what the
things that he he does I sometimes he
does political things as well well yeah
he has a very strong sense of history
but I think it's the history of Israel
and basically rather than any of the
historical parallels yeah
the Arabs or Palestinians who are
Israeli how do they act what is their
behavior Vasavi the Israeli to deserve
either jewels or visibility Arabs
however how are they but their
representatives like this guy TV and
some of the people that they've elected
to the Knesset to the Knesset yes are
extremely hostile to the Israeli
government and they don't make any bones
about it I mean they were on the Temple
Mount a wing Chiron went there and they
were throwing rocks and yelling and
carrying on basically there were fellow
politicians and the same Knesset and
were throwing stones at him yes Kennedy
this Temple Mount incident I never
understood it very well what would what
did he want to do he wanted to prove
this is ours fine then what well I think
he wanted he was running in an election
against Barak and and Barak you know
wanted to you know was before the
election no I was during the campaign
yes yeah I was right yeah I'm saying the
campaign he wanted you know Barak wanted
to give East Jerusalem to the
Palestinians he was making a statement
I'm gonna walk here you know which I
have a right to do and all hell's gonna
break loose and you know see what will
happen if Barack turns this over that
was what was I think in her head it
wasn't the smartest movie ever made
politically you knew that this was going
to happen no he didn't know it was gonna
be an inter father he thought that they
would start you know throwing rocks and
there would be riots I think he he had
to know that because when Netanyahu
opened that tunnel under the Temple
Mount wasn't even in the Temple Mount
they carried on you know and they
weren't it was it was underneath it was
he opened the door to the Via Dolorosa
because and they went people went nuts
you know and the Imams were yelling and
everything so he knew when he went there
that he was going to cause
uproar what he didn't know was that the
Intifada was planted it was gonna go off
for two years wasn't it wasn't a bright
move but it was political in my opinion
I can't think why else he would do it I
support that appeal okay anyone else
[Applause]
Anita and Jourdan Miller are the
founders of Academy Chicago publishers
which put out their book sharone
Israel's warrior politician visit info
at Academy Chicago dot-com for more
information